welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and the Terminator
franchise is back with the release of
Dark fate dropping in the UK today
throughout this video we'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the new film as well as its ending
we're also going to be discussing
whether this is the franchise's
salvation or if it's given it a dark
fate there will be heavy spoilers here
so if you haven't seen the film yet and
don't want anything ruined then I highly
recommend that you turn off now without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
our breakdown of terminator dark fate
okay so for the guy that said he hated
that alien three killed off mutant Hicks
because it crapped on the franchise
James Cameron she likes to contradict
himself this is because dark fade opens
with John Connor being murdered with the
shotgun at a beach bar in Guatemala
right in front of Sarah it's quite a big
slap in the face and for someone that's
been waiting for a supposed real sequel
to terminate a - for almost 30 years
this really annoyed me it's cheap out
the blue and doesn't feel like a proper
send-off for a character that we've come
to love now it is revealed in the film
that Skynet was destroyed and that Sarah
and John did manage to stop Judgment Day
however before its collapse Skynet sent
back several terminators and this one
had been hunting John for a while
eventually catching up to him there the
future has changed though and in place
of Skynet a new AI has risen known as
Legion that is an anti-terrorist program
in the future it causes an electronic
blackout worldwide and then wipes out
the majority of humanity with nukes
before hunting the rest with terminators
future leader of the resistance
danny has sent back one of her closest
friends Grace and enhanced human to
protect her and whilst all of this is
revealed later in the movie I thought
I'd drop it here just to set the stage
for what's to come now after the John
Connor death scene we cut to Danny and a
family in present-day after going to
work with her brother a new terminator
known as the red nine lands in her
apartment block kills her father takes
his form and then travels to where she
works to assassinate her the Rev nine is
different from the normal kind of
terminator because it's actually
comprised of two parts a liquid shell
that can move create weapons and morph
and a solid skull in structure beneath
that similar to the t800 it also has far
more emotional range than the typical
machine and can interact with people on
a human level making it far better at
infiltration grace intercepts the
Terminator and with Danny and her
brother they escape to a highway with
the Rev hot in pursuit now this action
scene really sets the pace for the movie
and whilst it's all stuff that we've
seen before when Sarah Connor returns to
save the group she really lights up the
screen and it's
testament to Linda Hamilton's charisma
of just how much she nails this role the
rev 9 manages to kill Danny's brother
but with the help of Conner grace and
Danny are able to commandeer her car and
escape
we learn that grace has a very high
metabolism that allows for short bursts
of energy which is perfect for tackling
terminators but in the long run this can
lead to prolonged fatigue and
powerlessness
whenever the plot needs her to be out
the way Conner manages to catch up with
them and it's revealed that she knew
about the Terminator coming for Danny
because she receives encrypted text
messages from an unknown source that
informs her of coordinates that attacks
will happen at she trusts these because
they're signed off for John and after
grace hacks her phone she's able to
determine the location of the texts
which also lines up with coordinates
that she has tattooed on a body this
takes the group to Texas and it's very
much a game of cat and mouse the entire
way with the Rev 9 constantly one step
behind them using Danny's digital
footprint a tracker across the border we
get an awesome scene at the border
detainment camp but ultimately for me
this action felt a bit hollow due to the
overuse of CGI in special effects that
strip the scenes of any real gravitas I
don't know what it is but I feel like
the longer this series has gone on the
more that each version is try to invent
a new a cool a terminator and it just
keeps trying to go up and up and up when
at its core the original design is still
the most intimidating one just something
about that cold unfeeling machine stays
with you and giving it a personality as
we see with the rebbe 9 just takes away
the horror element for me now eventually
the group get to the coordinates and
discover the terminator that killed John
all those years ago he is now taken on
the name call and after completing his
mission he began to learn from humanity
and decided to settle down with a
girlfriend and her son after becoming
attached to the boy he realized what he
had taken from Sara and due to his
conscience has decided to help her yeah
it's another one of those that I think
the audience will really struggle with
especially the die-hard fans however
Arnold does a great job at least of
delivering the lines and next to Linda
Hamilton he does have a positive
influence in the film even if some of
the logic leaps sounds stupid they
decided the best way to kill the rebbe
now
is to pile together as many weapons as
they can and create a kill box they also
think that an EMP will come in handy and
Sarah calls on her military contacts to
get one this takes them to an airport
base where the red line intercepts them
and after taking to the air the group
are brought down by the machine which
makes them crash land at a dam even
though they have no weapons or anything
and graces on our last legs they decide
that this is the best time to create the
kill box and in the machine room they
fight the rebbe nine now for some reason
the rebbe nine tries to barter with call
because they've been in each other's
shoes and he just wants the girl and he
let them go if they hand her over yeah
it's it's just really stupid and makes
no sense
I dunno whites in the movie anyway they
managed to destroy the rebbe 9 by
throwing him into a hydro pump which
strips one layer of its skin and grace
sacrifices herself in order to allow
Danny to pull her power cell out which
she jams into the Terminator the Rev 9
tries to kill Danny becaus steps in
grabs the Machine and pulls him down a
pit when they are both destroyed by the
exploding Power Cell in the end Danny
and Sarah set off together and the movie
closes with Danny looking over grace as
a child before Sara says that if she
wants to save her then she has to be
ready this kind of doesn't make sense
because she will still ultimately need
to send her back which he knows will
lead to her death but the to drive off
together into the future preparing for
what's to come
there's no post-credit scene and yep
another terrible Terminator film but
what did I think of dark fate overall
you may be wondering well yet again it
feels like another entry in the
franchise that is frustrating at points
due to its inability to really live up
to its full potential
I went in with very low expectations and
still ended up disappointed which is
just this is there I no longer care
about this series this is the third
attempt at new Terminator trilogy and at
this point it just seems like no studio
can truly deliver a worthy successor to
the first two films there's a lot of
logic leaps and the things that really
do my head in are that the rebbe 9 can
split into two but Riley does this
during opportunities where it would be
for there are several instances where I
could have easily killed Danny had it
separated but the Machine refuses to do
so because of reasons
there's also John Connors death which
though I don't want to keep going on
about it it just really wrecked the film
for me it pretty much ruins Terminator
and Terminator 2 and it also strips this
film of any real importance because if
the savior of mankind can change then
what's the point in saving Danny just
let her die and another hero can pop up
a no James Cameron has said that Marvel
movies are getting in the way of cinema
but I would much rather watch 22 more
MCU films and have another Terminator
movie that's this bad I don't want to
keep ripping into the film so I will
talk about some of the positives though
there were few so Oni has always been a
major factor in the Terminator franchise
making appearances in every film and
some former under there since its
inception the true star of this film
though is Linda Hamilton who feels like
the missing ingredient from the prior
entries she is by far the best part of
the movie and watching her blast through
action scene to action scene is
definitely the film's strong point now
the movie does take several risks both
narrative Lee and character wise
relegating a couple of fan favorites in
place of new ones though the film
achieves this in some respects it also
falls slightly sure with Natalie arias
who plays the new savior of mankind
looking pale in comparison to Hamilton
when sharing the screen with her now if
you were worried that this movie would
be too woke for its own good then you'll
be happy to know that I don't think the
film forces its message on us and though
things like certain settings are clear
comments on modern society they aren't
heavy-handed in a way that makes them I
rollin lis bad terminate a Dark Fae is
very much a turn your brain off movie
and it's sad that a film that is meant
to be a direct sequel to one of the
greatest action movies ever made balls
really flat James Cameron at this point
really can't be trusted when he boasts
that every Terminator sequel is the true
sequel and here is another entry that I
feel will be met with some
disappointment we now have a trilogy of
failed Terminator trilogies and it will
be interesting to see where the
franchise goes from now on a
surely they can't make another reboot
overall terminator is a bad film in my
eyes and we as fans deserve far much
more I wish that we could get Skylar to
just go back in time and terminate
everything after the second film but as
far as terminator sequels go this is
very underwhelming I never thought I'd
say it but Terminator 3 actually wasn't
that bad and I'd much rather have that
as the continuity than this one because
wow I just really disliked it terminated
dark fate gets a four out of ten now
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on terminator dark fate and if you agree
with me or not comment below and let me
know and if you enjoy this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my breakdown of this week's other
big release at the lighthouse which
would be linked at the end I go over
everything that you need to know about
the movie as well as my interpretation
of the ending so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more if
you want to come chat to me after the
video that make sure you follow me on
twitter at definition whitey or head
over to my discord server which would be
linked in the description below those
are the best ways to keep up to date
with all the latest videos on the
channel so hopefully I see you over
there very soon we're also giving away a
free copy of the Marvel phase 3 part 1
box out on blu-ray which contains Civil
War Doctor Strange homecoming Ragnarok
and more and all you have to do to be
end with a chance of winning it's like
the video make sure that you subscribe
to the channel and leave your thoughts
on Doc fate in the comments below the
winners gonna be chosen on the 15th of
November and the set will be shipped out
from then to ever get surprise so best
of luck to everyone who takes part this
is the channel for people who were mad
into movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best let's see you next time take care
peace
you